and now ladies and gentlemen comic that
most you probably haven't heard of Bryan
Callen no no it's he's kind of a big
deal though he's a big deal
you know how I know it's hot when we
post certain guests yeah Instagram some
guests we just say hey we have this
person and send Brian Brennan questions
but for you we all hey we had jokowi
coming it good news just your fans like
what can I ask you what's your favorite
UFC fight of all time my favorite yeah
fight or fighter my favorite fight Frank
Maris Brock Lesnar oh yeah that was good
because I think cuz the - that presented
like dude he's a martial artist like
Brock Lesnar and this come from a guy
who came from Brock more Brock Lesnar
and fraying there but brocklander came
from the WWE and you know a lot to hide
that always will be faked I don't we
just think that's all fake they do get
hurt but it's fake it's not what we do
there's nothing on the line or like what
we do it's not the [ __ ] same it's not
a sport it's a it's a it's basically
stuntmen in they're entertainers they're
actors that put a lot of they get wear
and tear on them so when he came over
although he was a legit wrestler there's
I felt like it was this first them and
Frank Mir it was like God man how's he
gonna win this when he submitted him I
was like [ __ ] yeah yeah I forget that I
was in Arizona at the Super Bowl
watching them
I remember when when Brock came at him
and I think he they threw him up against
the the fence and and just the way the
whole fence moved I don't think I've
ever seen that this is how Huber Brock
this isn't Brock now with all the
testing this is Brock Brock we make a
career out of what you get what usually
is considered to be disruptive yeah yeah
I'll be a jackass yeah exactly yeah
you're not gonna make anything out of
comedy my mom was not happy with that do
you think teachers want to be a nurse
though do you think teachers and other
people are saying because these days
yeah ways to make money yeah I think
like if my kids a jackass like me or
like you guys I'm gonna tell them like
there's avenues to make money off there
sure oh yeah so many avenues we're
before especially when you guys would
coming up hell no what are you doing
I mean idiot telling jokes yeah later I
mean you were always a driven guy into
very well in sports and middle
but there's something amazing about kind
of the first time you realize that you
have there is a door there is a door to
salvation yeah
in other words like when I was growing
up I remember watching my dad go to work
every day I watched people go to work
every day and I was like well that might
be good for some people but if I have to
put on a suit and go to work every day I
might die if I have to do those kinds of
civilian things I'm not I knew from an
early age I wasn't cut out for it you
have to do that job sure yeah everyone
have everybody going comedy then you're
on [ __ ] you got the Comedy Store
doing you know a main in the main room
yeah yeah talk about when you see the
door get out of there right so you're
like if I just keep doing this that
doors gonna open eventually yeah yeah if
you just keep yeah it's a numbers game
basically yeah but I mean Brian like
what back when we were doing it I mean I
mean we're still doing it but like that
that that that that transition part
while I was working three jobs you know
Howard Hughes is right around here right
the Howard Hughes Parkway okay so I used
to work at Borders Books in North sanrak
they were right on top of each other so
I worked from Borders Books from seven
to ten and then from 12 to nine I was at
Nordstrom Rack like back when me and
Brian were at the Laugh Factory yeah 20
minutes I just got off he was killing
mrs. field he was destroying he would
destroy the last Factory on a Saturday
like oh if you I said before you got on
I said if you're gonna follow Joe Coyte
you better be yeah and you are but but
yes but that that that were working
there and I have my son he was just one
he was one at that time and I just
remember my mom like looking at me like
Joseph I told you dis comedy like your
son's going to get older like how much
more abuse are you gonna do like
literally just quit she even gave me
money for a car she's like here I'll buy
you a car you don't have to worry about
car payment like she was doing all of
that no mom you don't understand this is
this is what I want to do I remember it
is so funny that you said that about
Sebastian because I remember him in his
waiter out waiter going in here going up
on stage
and then I was the same thing I was I
was uh cleaning yachts on Saturday
nights right here on Playa del Rey they
Marina del Rey where they take the
yachts out and I had to clean them and I
remember it's just starting to bus the
tables early because I knew the sooner I
can get done I can rush over to the
Laugh Factory did you have any contact
with krokodil eh
no I've been up there I've seen them
they're pretty impressive
they're pretty horrifying oh yeah but I
would I would much rather deal with
sharks and cross yeah it's weird me in
the croc they don't like the way I taste
this when a girl likes a guy you guys
have a girl yeah yeah that they went
swimming in a waterway that was
signposted as having crocodiles at night
listen girl you got a look there's my
girl drunk no I think she was probably
late 20s drunk yeah just decided to go
for a swim and I think it was in
northern Queensland it wasn't even in in
Mexico no this is Australia just decided
to go for a swim in not in northern
Queensland no you don't got eaten Oh
friend jumping oh yeah that's right we
get tourists up there alone so one guy -
getting a tan one got bit yep and they
are scary and then I just just bought
you and let go they'll bite you they'll
flip it out they'll do the death roll
trying to twist you two paces trying to
kill you
then they'll stick you under a log ten
minutes yes are you decomposed and
they'll come back and I eat yeah that's
scary they might be this animal I would
agree that it's Lily that it's not you
know sharks they look confused they
might bite you like oh I cried a lot and
they learn they'll watch people coming
up to the water to collect their daily
water rations and things like that and
they'll time it they don't know what
yeah I saw a video where it said careful
alligators on the up side of this fence
from Alexander 28
what is the biggest change in your life
since the shark attack there's been so
many initially obviously not having a
hand in a leg that's so pretty like a
very big giant I think yeah yeah
use your hand and leg not being it yeah
that really messes up your ability to
squat and bench press luckily I have
tools for that now so but uh you know
everything has changed every aspect of
my life has changed I've become a
different person you know like I said I
was scared of sharks and public speaking
now I make shock documentaries and do
motivational speaking so my careers
change my mind sets changed it has a
really my mindset hasn't changed just
developed further yeah well you left the
right-hander's oh there you go I'm
left-handed now yeah that makes a huge
difference that learning to write left
hand in learning how to how to do things
one hand and how do you open a can with
one hand how do you use a dustman broom
how do you tie your shoelaces all these
little things how do you do up buttons
and do your ties and all these little
things you got to relearn how to do and
they're so frustrating until you just
learn yeah you have a choice and it's
amazing what you can do when you don't
have a choice that's all right it's it's
it's difficult I me a chat with them
John Jones
add the LA Fitness Expo when I was up
here like six months ago you know the
first question he asked me he checked
off with that robot hand I was like [ __ ]
John oh I'll let you get away